Here's how our virtual memory system will
work.
The memory addresses generated by the CPU
are called virtual addresses to distinguish
them from the physical addresses used by main
memory.
In between the CPU and main memory there's
a new piece of hardware called the memory
management unit (MMU).
The MMU's job is to translate virtual addresses
to physical addresses.
"But wait!" you say.
"Doesn't the cache go between the CPU and
main memory?"
You're right and at the end of this lecture
we'll talk about how to use both an MMU and
a cache.
But for now, let's assume there's only an
MMU and no cache.
The MMU hardware translates virtual addresses
to physical addresses using a simple table
lookup.
This table is called the page map or page
table.
Conceptually, the MMU uses the virtual address
as index to select an entry in the table,
which tells us the corresponding physical
address.
The table allows a particular virtual address
to be found anywhere in main memory.
In normal operation we'd want to ensure that
two virtual addresses don't map to the same
physical address.
But it would be okay if some of the virtual
addresses did not have a translation to a
physical address.
This would indicate that the contents of the
requested virtual address haven't yet been
loaded into main memory, so the MMU would
signal a memory-management exception to the
CPU,
which could assign a location in physical
memory and perform the required I/O operation
to initialize that location from secondary
storage.
The MMU table gives the system a lot of control
over how physical memory is accessed by the
program running on the CPU.
For example, we could arrange to run multiple
programs in quick succession (a technique
called time sharing) by changing the page
map when we change programs.
Main memory locations accessible to one program
could be made inaccessible to another program
by proper management of their respective page
maps.
And we could use memory-management exceptions
to load program contents into main memory
on demand instead of having to load the entire
program before execution starts.
In fact, we only need to ensure the current
working set of a program is actually resident
in main memory.
Locations not currently being used could live
in secondary storage until needed.
In this lecture and next, we'll see how the
MMU plays a central role in the design of
a modern timesharing computer system.
Of course, we'd need an impossibly large table
to separately map each virtual address to
a physical address.
So instead we divide both the virtual and
physical address spaces into fixed-sized blocks,
called pages.
Page sizes are always a power-of-2 bytes,
say 2^p bytes, so p is the number address
bits needed to select a particular location
on the page.
We'll the use low-order p bits of the virtual
or physical address as the page offset.
The remaining address bits tell us which page
is being accessed and are called the page
number.
A typical page size is 4KB to 16KB, which
correspond to p=12 and p=14 respectively.
Suppose p=12.
If the CPU produces a 32-bit virtual address,
the low-order 12 bits of the virtual address
are the page offset and the high-order 20
bits are the virtual page number.
Similarly, the low-order p bits of the physical
address are the page offset and the remaining
physical address bits are the physical page
number.
The key idea is that the MMU will manage pages,
not individual locations.
We'll move entire pages from secondary storage
into main memory.
By the principal of locality, if a program
access one location on a page, we expect it
will soon access other nearby locations.
By choosing the page offset from the low-order
address bits, we'll ensure that nearby locations
live on the same page (unless of course we're
near one end of the page or the other).
So pages naturally capture the notion of locality.
And since pages are large, by dealing with
pages when accessing secondary storage,
we'll take advantage that reading or writing
many locations is only slightly more time
consuming than accessing the first location.
The MMU will map virtual page numbers to physical
page numbers.
It does this by using the virtual page number
(VPN) as an index into the page table.
Each entry in the page table indicates if
the page is resident in main memory and, if
it is, provides the appropriate physical page
number (PPN).
The PPN is combined with the page offset to
form the physical address for main memory.
If the requested virtual page is NOT resident
in main memory, the MMU signals a memory-management
exception, called a page fault, to the CPU
so it can load the appropriate page from secondary
storage and set up the appropriate mapping
in the MMU.
Our plan to use main memory as page cache
is called "paging" or sometimes "demand paging"
since movements of pages to and from secondary
storage is determined by the demands of the
program.
So here's the plan.
Initially all the virtual pages for a program
reside in secondary storage and the MMU is
empty, i.e., there are no pages resident in
physical memory.
The CPU starts running the program and each
virtual address it generates, either for an
instruction fetch or data access, is passed
to the MMU to be mapped to a physical address
in main memory.
If the virtual address is resident in physical
memory, the main memory hardware can complete
the access.
If the virtual address in NOT resident in
physical memory, the MMU signals a page fault
exception, forcing the CPU to switch execution
to special code called the page fault handler.
The handler allocates a physical page to hold
the requested virtual page and loads the virtual
page from secondary storage into main memory.
It then adjusts the page map entry for the
requested virtual page to show that it is
now resident and to indicate the physical
page number for the newly allocated and initialized
physical page.
When trying to allocate a physical page, the
handler may discover that all physical pages
are currently in use.
In this case it chooses an existing page to
replace, e.g., a resident virtual page that
hasn't been recently accessed.
It swaps the contents of the chosen virtual
page out to secondary storage and updates
the page map entry for the replaced virtual
page to indicate it is no longer resident.
Now there's a free physical page to re-use
to hold the contents of the virtual page that
was missing.
The working set of the program, i.e., the
set of pages the program is currently accessing,
is loaded into main memory through a series
of page faults.
After a flurry of page faults when the program
starts running, the working set changes slowly,
so the frequency of page faults drops dramatically,
perhaps close to zero if the program is small
and well-behaved.
It is possible to write programs that consistently
generate page faults, a phenomenon called
thrashing.
Given the long access times of secondary storage,
a program that's thrashing runs *very* slowly,
usually so slowly that users give up and rewrite
the program to behave more sensibly.
The design of the page map is straightforward.
There's one entry in the page map for each
virtual page.
For example, if the CPU generates a 32-bit
virtual address and the page size is 2^12
bytes, the virtual page number has 32-12 = 20
bits and the page table will have 2^20 entries.
Each entry in the page table contains a "resident
bit" (R) which is set to 1 when the virtual
page is resident in physical memory.
If R is 0, an access to that virtual page
will cause a page fault.
If R is 1, the entry also contains the PPN,
indicating where to find the virtual page
in main memory.
There's one additional state bit called the
"dirty bit" (D).
When a page has just been loaded from secondary
storage, it's "clean", i.e, the contents of
physical memory match the contents of the
page in secondary storage.
So the D bit is set to 0.
If subsequently the CPU stores into a location
on the page, the D bit for the page is set
to 1, indicating the page is "dirty", i.e.,
the contents of memory now differ from the
contents of secondary storage.
If a dirty page is ever chosen for replacement,
its contents must be written to secondary
storage in order to save the changes before
the page gets reused.
Some MMUs have additional state bits in each
page table entry.
For example, there could be a "read-only"
bit which, when set, would generate an exception
if the program attempts to store into the
page.
This would be useful for protecting code pages
from accidentally being corrupted by errant
data accesses, a very handy debugging feature.
Here's an example of the MMU in action.
To make things simple, assume that the virtual
address is 12 bits, consisting of an 8-bit
page offset and a 4-bit virtual page number.
So there are 2^4 = 16 virtual pages.
The physical address is 11 bits, divided into
the same 8-bit page offset and a 3-bit physical
page number.
So there are 2^3 = 8 physical pages.
On the left we see a diagram showing the contents
of the 16-entry page map, i.e., an entry for
each virtual page.
Each page table entry includes a dirty bit
(D), a resident bit (R) and a 3-bit physical
page number, for a total of 5 bits.
So the page map has 16 entries, each with
5-bits, for a total of 16*5 = 80 bits.
The first entry in the table is for virtual
page 0, the second entry for virtual page
1, and so on.
In the middle of the slide there's a diagram
of physical memory showing the 8 physical
pages.
The annotation for each physical page shows
the virtual page number of its contents.
Note that there's no particular order to how
virtual pages are stored in physical memory
-
which page holds what is determined by which
pages are free at the time of a page fault.
In general, after the program has run for
a while, we'd expected to find the sort of
jumbled ordering we see here.
Let's follow along as the MMU handles the
request for virtual address 0x2C8, generated
by the execution of the LD instruction shown
here.
Splitting the virtual address into page number
and offset, we see that the VPN is 2 and the
offset is 0xC8.
Looking at the page map entry with index 2,
we see that the R bit is 1, indicating that
virtual page 2 is resident in physical memory.
The PPN field of entry tells us that virtual
page 2 can be found in physical page 4.
Combining the PPN with the 8-bit offset, we
find that the contents of virtual address
0x2C8 can be found in main memory location
0x4C8.
Note that the offset is unchanged by the translation
process -
the offset into the physical page is always
the same as the offset into the virtual page.